huh here we go again it's time for us to
take another crack at putting
scp-682 six feet under once and for all
if you've been following this channel
for any amount of time then there's one
thing you know for certain
scp-682 is harder to kill than pretty
much well
anything we've made multiple videos on
the foundation's failed attempts to
finally terminate the beast and we've
made a video with some of your ideas on
how to finally slay the monster and
considering you're watching this video
right now you can probably guess how
that went now it's time for one more run
at the death star and once again it's
with your ideas from comments and
community post responses let's see if
any of them can help us finally put this
ill-tempered reptile to rest if we can't
well we're not blaming you but it's also
your fault let the community termination
attempts commence anas mcbride suggested
ask the witch child scp-230
also known as the witch child is one of
the most dangerous and powerful
anomalies out there she's a small girl
with unparalleled reality warping mental
abilities so powerful that her very
brainwaves alone can be passively fatal
however the problem is her power is so
potentially dangerous that she's forever
kept in a kind of medically induced
anomalous coma dr alto clef thinks she's
so dangerous he's even campaigning to
have her terminated as a result the o5
council has forbidden any cross testing
between 682 and 239 fearing the
consequence of 682 gaining 239's powers
and becoming a truly unstoppable threat
capable causing an xk class end of the
world scenario siad zamin ali shah
kazimi mushadi suggested kill him with
scp-734
this is an interesting one scp-734
also known as the baby is an anomaly
that causes a painful degenerative
disease that eventually disintegrates
the entire body and kills the victim if
they so much as come into contact with
the baby or its fluids however based on
cross tests with other similar touch-it
and dye anomalies like
scp-409 the contagious crystal we can
probably guess how exactly this would go
down in all likelihood the baby's
anomalous effects would infect and
destroy large portions of
scp-682's body however at this point 682
would adapt to the threat and begin to
reverse it and heal even worse it's
likely that 682 would steal the ability
for a limited time and become deadly to
the touch kaden griffin suggested why
don't you use the dragon slayer to
terminate 682 it has proved itself many
times in fights with lsas
scp-5514 the dragon slayer is
essentially a giant fighting robot
designed to take down killer kaijus with
its plethora of state-of-the-art
anomalous weapons and defenses however
we'd still argue that while it could
definitely help in immobilizing 682
during a rampage it doesn't have much of
a chance of actually killing it let's
look at scp-001
the gate guardian a supernatural warrior
with a blade hotter than the sun capable
of cleaving atoms in half even he
couldn't kill
scp-682 so robotic approximation with
only a fraction of the gate guardian's
power is probably not going to have any
real chance of killing 682. i'ma
chuckster 48 suggested make it bite its
tongue so hard that it just destroys
itself while we can certainly attest
from personal experience that this
really really hurts we worry that if
ever 682 bit its own tongue really hard
it'd just drive it into a state of
murderous rage though we do take a small
piece of satisfaction and knowing its
tongue would probably be in distress for
a few minutes afterwards it's unlikely
to wipe out the beast once and for all
lacie royce suggested how about we just
put scp-682 in 2317 cell
scp-2317 is an old wooden door that
functions as a portal into the domain of
the planet-destroying monster known as
the devourer of worlds a being that many
believe is associated with the scarlet
king and will inevitably escape and
cause an xk-class end of the world
scenario while you may be thinking
perhaps it'll kill 682 it's more likely
that it'll collaborate seeing as they
both want the same thing namely to kill
everyone if you let 682 in chances are
it'll come back through the door with
the devourer right on its tail then it's
all of our problems guest 123116
suggested drop him in russia so they can
terminate him the foundation has
technically already tried this they
dropped 682 into scp-3930
a patch of literal non-existence in
russia that causes anything that goes
inside of it to cease to exist and
afterwards he was fine so yeah dropping
him anywhere in russia is probably just
going to get a bunch of innocent russian
civilians killed meisher said the
foundation shouldn't worry about how to
kill him but how to stop his ability to
adapt i would suggest typing scp-682 no
adaptability juice or something like
that into scp-294 and then kill him by
any means which should kill him forever
an interesting theory but what if he
simply adapts to scp-682 no adaptability
juice then we'd really all be in trouble
mario tgp said give him a twitter
account he'll be cancelled instantly for
his spicy opinions
scp-682 would cancel twitter itself for
not having opinions that are spicy
enough sorry jack
scp-096 still sore about losing the
battle we assume said let him fight the
queen of england after all she's
immortal too we definitely think it
would be interesting to see scp-682 go
head-to-head with the queen of england
based on all the knighting she does we
know that she at least has a sword
though we don't know if that sword is as
powerful as the one wielded by the gate
guardian but regardless of the outcome
the battle would definitely change
history every history book would simply
read
scp-682 punch the queen everything else
would just be a footnote noah cordero
said use
scp-2935 to kill the lizard as you can
see in the video he will die scp-2935
also known as oh death is probably one
of the scariest and deadliest scps out
there it killed an entire alternate
dimension including an alternate scp-682
the problem is putting r682 into 2935's
alternate reality could lead to the
destruction of our entire dimension why
is that because if 682 was somehow able
to return to our world from the world of
2935
it could bring the spirit of death
itself back with it and kill us all in
the process explorando combato 1
suggested
scp-682 versus lady dimatrisk while
resident evil 8's lady dimatrisk has
certainly captured all of our
hearts we don't think she'll be bringing
home the w on this one lady demetrisk
has a powerful adaptive ability of her
own with a high resistance to damage
impressive regenerative abilities and a
number of offensive capabilities from
huge claws to a powerful dragon form
however considering she wasn't able to
defeat ethan winters she probably
wouldn't be able to defeat
scp-682 either however in her dragon
form as cp 682 may finally join the rest
of us in developing a crush or is that
being crushed anyway moving on jonathan
pekkins suggested just ask scp-343 on
how to destroy it or even better ask if
he could destroy it it's an idea so good
that the foundation actually tried it
and it went about as well as you can
expect when the scp known as god entered
the containment chamber he couldn't even
see 682 in there as though the creature
was somehow totally invisible to him
when god eventually got bored and left
they told him that he was in there to
destroy 682 he simply replied he's not
one of mine deal with him yourself
interpret that how you will twelve
escobar blanca's eddie saul suggested
they could send him to area 37 for the
sisters to experiment with
scp-1765 the sisters are a trio of
terrifyingly powerful reality warpers
that have taken over area 37 and spend
their days tormenting everyone inside
with their twisted experiments using
them to try to terminate 682 leads to
similar problems with using the witch
child or the devourer of worlds if they
decide to team up rather than fighting
or the sisters take over 682 we'd all be
effectively doomed kiroya suggested with
the ants from
scp-743 tare 682 apart the foundation
actually tried this getting 682 to
consume chocolate from the scp-743
fountain incurring the wrath of its
flesh-eating ants however 682 developed
an adaptation that gave it a long
anteater-like tongue that had then used
to consume the ants faster than they
could consume it and even worse the
chocolate seemed to enhance its
regenerative abilities even more for
several days afterwards
ball2222 suggested write the name in the
death note great idea we'll put it into
practice as soon as you can tell us as
cp 682's real name it may come as a
surprise but its parents didn't actually
name it the hard to destroy reptile
steven very suggested i thought that
maybe we should put him in a giant
blender and then when he's in small
pieces put lava in the blender so we'll
incinerate him then put nuclear waste
into the blender and repeat that until
there's no more left of him after the
cooking whisks last time we feel obliged
to include at least one attempt to kill
scp-682 with oversized kitchen equipment
in every video about him however this
attempt would probably go about as well
as the last one we're afraid extreme
physical trauma by conventional means
like burning and dismemberment has never
been successful in the past and the
foundation is extremely hesitant to use
anything radioactive on the beast in
case it adapts and adds deadly radiation
to its own arsenal mr master iq
suggested just take away his plot armor
you can pry
scp-682's plot armor from its cold dead
claws and as we've already learned
making those claws cold and dead seems
next to impossible moving on jc3
suggested hmm if anyone can't beat the
undying lizard why not omniman i mean he
did kill all the guardians of the globe
of course he can kill
scp-682 omni man from the comic and tv
series invincible is undeniably a
formidable opponent given he's able to
destroy superhero teams cities and even
planets however one of the few enemies
to give omniman a genuine run for his
money is a genetically enhanced kaiju
known as hail mary given that first 682
has taken on being stronger than omniman
like the gate guardian and lived and
second that omniman has struggled with
monsters before chances are he probably
couldn't permanently kill this one
either hey kenny javaya suggested kill
scp-053 then 682 will be sad and die
wow now that's cold-blooded however even
if this did work it's important for you
to remember that it's impossible to
actually kill scp-053
also known as the child or the little
girl part of her anomalous abilities is
that anyone who attempts to kill her
will themselves immediately die during
the process normally due to a heart
attack so this method would result in a
pile of dead foundation personnel and no
progress jerry zhang said mush peanut
butter on it this would definitely work
if 682 had some kind of severe peanut
allergy after all anaphylactic shock is
no laughing matter however in the far
more likely event that this will have no
effect on scp-682
you will likely just die with your hands
covered in peanut butter andrew mills
suggested my idea have several
xenomorphs predators and daleks yes
that's a doctor who reference take 682
on once again in all likelihood this
would have no effect 682 has survived
blades and lasers the primary weapons of
the predators and daleks and spends the
majority of its life immersed in
powerful acid so the xenomorph would
hold no surprises for it sadly this
three-way team-up would be no match for
682 and even if it did defeat him
whoever wins we
well
you know how it goes mateo huang
suggested maybe just destroy reality
this
this might be the thing that finally
kills scp-682
but considering it's already survived
being thrown into pure nothingness in
russia it may just result in it being
one of the only survivors of a full
destruction of reality we on the other
hand would all be killed though in a
sense we wouldn't have to deal with
scp-682 anymore so maybe that's a type
of winning and finally blind honor
suggested would saitama be a good way to
eliminate it he is one punch man after
all of anyone we've covered in this
series saitama from one punch man would
probably be the most likely to kill
scp-682 especially if he was taking the
battle seriously after all he has killed
planet destroying monsters before with
barely any effort the only real question
is whether he could be bothered to come
down to a foundation containment site
and fight it saitama hasn't been known
to be a very motivated guy but of course
like with anything there's the risk that
682 would survive and gain his powers
which would be bad awesome but bad do
you have new ideas for how scp-682 could
be killed do you think you have the key
to finally bringing this beast to a
well-deserved end let us know down in
the comments and keep an eye on our
community post for more scp questions
like this one so you can be featured in
the next video now go check out
termination attempts scp-682
and how to kill
scp-682 theories and ideas for more
futile attempts to murder the
foundation's ornariest reptile